we're going deep tonight
what's happening baby boy i got the bond
squad tattoo do you really you're that
[ __ ] oh my god you're [ __ ]
beautiful
you are [ __ ] beautiful without that
guy i'm dead
he was uh tremendous man a lot of people
somebody called me the other day and
asked me who to name the the top three
front men yeah
and i brought up bonsai and they're like
ah he's no freddie america i go you know
what oh was that don barris no i got
i've seen [ __ ] bond scott
august 4th in 1979 i was a young kid
opening up for ted nugent that's all the
same
weekend warriors at madison square
garden
he was amazing that's when he went out
in the audience and he [ __ ] did the
whole thing on angus would get on his
shoulders people would lose that that
was way before the pit the whole [ __ ]
thing stinky people jumping up and down
that was way before that
i mean then i saw him the next year i'm
back in black right with brian it was
amazing it was like the guy died on my
birthday february 19th yeah and uh
[ __ ]
you know they had a new singer and they
were ready to rock i think they were
opening for judas priest when i saw him
i mean i saw a priest i had to say
[ __ ] 15 times yeah i saw a priest too
and i heard that when they were in town
two weeks ago they were just phenomenal
i was there
oh man i couldn't believe it there was
uh i was
i went because i did the nokia center
two nights ago with the rest of two
nights before with the russell peters so
i'm backstage and there's like the gm so
i go yeah i really want to see priest
and two minutes later they gave me this
[ __ ] envelope with seats and passes
and [ __ ] so i took danny from the store
oh
yeah i said we're going to priest and
we're going in [ __ ] luxury and man
they came on and they played like
jawbreaker you know jawbreaker
[ __ ] killing man and uh
love bites they did a lot of stuff off
the um
defenders of the faith record that's
when i jumped off the bike yeah by that
time i was bugging people but that time
it was yeah yeah i think i was there for
uh heading out to the highway and i was
done so they had the point entry record
that's the for the entry and then the
one after that what was the one after
that not to the highway i got none to
lose that was it that's pointless
yeah i was done by that time yeah by
that time i was way done i was solar
angels is amazing that's what they used
to open up with that's when they don't
remember and they came out
listen i uh
it was november i didn't know anything
about anything and a friend of mine had
a hat that said
jesus christ
but in the jesus christ it said judas
priest right and i go what the [ __ ] is
that
and uh the next day we were in study
hall
and the next day he brought me an
eight-track of unleashed in the east oh
and i went home and threw that
[ __ ] on and there was i didn't
understand like i was still into i was
still in love with the son of man is the
same oh yeah that was it i came home and
yeah and then by that time when this kid
steve had given me this cassette or a
track whatever i went home and i heard
i was blown the [ __ ] away yeah
the center green man elizabeth victim a
change just just all that [ __ ] exciter
and uh look at that stand back from
excellent
oh my god so oh man it was really
[ __ ] and i never told the story i was
really [ __ ] depressed it was two
weeks after my mom died
it was the week before it was the
weekend after thanksgiving
that's saturday after thanksgiving
and my friends we're going to go see
priests my mama you want to come and i'm
like nah
and at six o'clock i go what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me they're playing the
palladium yeah going to see a band of
the palladium was like going to the main
room at the comedy store
that's what it was like going to the
main small
small they had a
you know they had 2 000 seats but you
know it was a movie theater with 2 000
seats
and i went over there by myself and i
got tickets for 20 bucks and i went in
and they came out of the [ __ ]
motorcycle and that was 79 november 29
1979
that [ __ ] pulled off with a
motorcycle and during the center he
whipped out a whip yeah and started just
whipping it was whipping the tank i was
i left there i didn't know what to do
and i had a little bit of blow yeah and
i took the bus over in those days the
bus dropped me off on boulevard east
where i got mugged when i tried to mug
the gay guy i think he was gay it was a
pervert and he beat the [ __ ] on me and i
walked up that block
and i got into an altercation that night
i got into an altercation i got into an
argument with a guy about abroad
i had bumped into somebody
who was cheating
yeah i bumped into a
a guy that was cheating with a girl that
was a friend of a friend of mine
and i walked past him and i thought
about it i was by the book that like i
didn't like that [ __ ] at all and i
walked back
and i went off on her and i remember how
scared that was that i was gonna fight
this kid yeah but i didn't give a [ __ ] i
called her a [ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know he's in [ __ ] a bar right now
working to take you out during the week
yeah and here you are doing this and the
next day they turned it into like two
days later by the time i got to high
school that monday
they had turned it into almost domestic
violence
and it really wasn't like they were that
i pushed her i didn't push this check
yeah i just went back and i go you know
what you should be ashamed of yourself
and you
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean i just i
had a little i had a horrible assault oh
i had a little coke left in my system
and that girl didn't talk to me
for maybe two years her and the guy
broke up yeah she went to the guy and
told him something different and i
looked went to the guy who looked in his
eye and go this is what really happened
they were holding hands
i saw them don't [ __ ] tell me in fact
when i until this day that guy that i
went on is still around and when i go
back every once in a while he posts
something on facebook type of cute and i
just shut him the [ __ ] down
he still hangs out with some of my
friend's name is tommy nobody remembers
that though how like i just went off and
then years later that dumb chick
came up to me was cold out it was really
cold out and i had a and she was
drinking vodka and iced tea this is in
high school this is how pissed off i
still am she lives in fort lauderdale
and whenever i do the miami improv they
threaten me that they're all going to
come down and see me and i tell them no
christian's allowed [ __ ] you [ __ ] and
they stop they won't come yeah but this
dummy one night we're outside just get
out there you just get out it's gotta be
ten after eight and i see her with like
three other girls and i'm with another
guy and they're like where are you guys
going we're going over here and she had
a bottle of vodka and an iced tea by
this time i still hate this girl like i
had
at this age i just hated you yeah if you
did something stupid there was no i'm
sorry
and i saw her out yeah she was done and
she came up to me
and she was like
she said something she was trying to be
nice
and i go what's that on your jacket i
didn't know you were chili or something
and i i did something like i didn't know
you were chilling and when i walked away
about three minutes later she threw one
of the iced teas on me
just [ __ ] threw it on my new jacket
should i go [ __ ] this [ __ ]
i saw her she kept drinking
and she kept putting an iced tea on the
floor by that time the ice tree was a
little frozen
and i went behind the tiptoe and i took
the ice tea and i poured it over her
[ __ ] head and i saw the icicles
freezing up on her head and she came
back
and we didn't talk till 82
and then i see the coke dealer's house
and everything was all right i'm sorry
i'm sorry yeah when you see somebody at
the feeling
yeah once you see somebody at the
dealer's house everything's forgiven
yeah yeah you know what you weren't
supposed to see me here i was supposed
to see you there
what's up lisa yeah where the [ __ ] you
been i've been here but i watched
something you told me to watch did i
watch that arty lang howard stern
i wanted to get your opinion on two
things first thing was
i've dealt with some people who have
been addicts in my life
and a lot of them
are masters
of talking their way out of of trying to
convince people that it's not as bad as
it seems
and at that point already had only been
clean for like seven months if you look
it up it's like already
already does heroin it's something it's
like 30 minutes long 40 minutes
were you would you like that too wait
can you talk your way out of any
anything really anything and when i got
in this situation i was talking my way
out
just so i could get high
you have no idea when somebody squashes
your eye
like when you have plans about getting
high and somebody's you have plans
sure you don't want nobody know how deep
you really are
was already back on drugs no not no it
was it was back when he was still on the
show but he he uh joe just told me to
watch the video but classic radio
classic
radio there's
i never guys i never was into [ __ ]
radio i know he was i knew he was [ __ ]
i knew artie was [ __ ] up
14 years ago when i got a call
christmas week like a hurry up call to
go and audition for the kevin nealon
show because they thought about firing
them so i sat there with nick apollo
rocky laporte it must have been eight of
us
that they were just gonna pick up
because they thought he was crazy
already his berg's amazing the first one
too fat to fish that's the one it's
right before that came out because i
just opened for him about a month ago
how was this special his special just
came out i haven't had a chance of
watching him yeah bits and pieces that
are pretty funny he's sarcastic but then
you watch the video
did it seem like they were being mean to
him like i felt bad for him like howard
and then black people can't listen it's
good radio they want to get to the
bottom of it tell me what happened and
he kept pissing around it well i went to
this pool league i went down to shoe
pool nobody knows yeah but that's how
you talk everything is subtle it wasn't
asking questions but it was like they
were like the rob in the black was like
oh i knew you were doing it and then
they went around and followed him around
with a camera afterwards like is this
gonna be the time that you're clean and
i can only imagine like seven days into
being off heroin you don't really want a
camera stuck first of all we don't even
know if he was really off that's true
you have no idea you have no idea and
you pack your stories and you become a
master of [ __ ] when you're addicted
i love the guy i'm not putting him down
i love him no yeah you're on the show
when i called you and told you to watch
this
i called you because i thought it was
brilliant radio yeah it was really he's
got two of them on there well they break
them down for heroin yeah it's brilliant
radio it's brilliant [ __ ] radio man
i had never seen it and i wanted you to
see it that was it it was nice
i thought it was interesting it was just
uh
painful it was painful you could feel
this pain and you could feel
the lies and you could feel i had to
shut it off that's what you want me to
tell you how to shut it off i couldn't
watch the whole thing because i was
there right i put myself there when
you're there
you know that's when that's why i like
the interview how many conversations
have you had like that when someone's
like talking to you about your drug use
55
and then it'd be somebody really
you know off color that would talk to me
towards the end of the night
and i would get steamed the more and
more they talked they wouldn't know how
lucky they were they wouldn't know like
i would be seething inside and then i
either walk away
or i'd say something i have friends i
didn't talk to for two or three weeks
because of bringing [ __ ] up like you
know what
just knock it off don't worry about it
don't worry about rehab don't worry
about nothing
you know i got this we all think we have
this but we really don't i was the same
way with my weight if anybody had told
me no i would usually get pissed off
yeah you get defensive you get very
defensive and you can't you have to see
the source that's what would piss me off
it's the source
it's not
what you say it's how you say it in
those situations it's very tender you
know
did you ever do drugs thing oh
completely how long have you been clean
and soap before now i'm not clean and
sober in about 92 i just set them out
okay but uh mad piles of blow you still
drink it all the way no nothing nothing
no what happened was
uh i burned it up probably a good
ten years straight of just cocaine and
vodka and red hooks
you know
and then
like my voice was starting to take a
toll
you know the cocaine the cocaine just
destroys your voice
oh god yeah
booze and cigarettes people think oh
that guy sounds
great and he smokes and stuff that
doesn't phase your voice man your voice
is your voice but cocaine and no sleep
will wipe your voice out immediately
because a lot of things that happen are
when you're on coke
now you're talking way louder yeah man
well crumb crunch
all night about dumb [ __ ] about
going to disneyland next week we're
gonna ride the you know that ride or
whatever just dumb [ __ ] and you're
talking and talking and talking and your
voice just gets trashed and then you
don't sleep
and then you're going out singing
and it's it's over with for me my voice
would drop that's how you knew i did a
blast yeah my throat would close
because
i would whisper just because i wanted
you to whisper
so i would whisper so you whispered
and my mentality if i whispered you
would
what you know why would you why would
you want them that's why because i don't
want i don't want to hear loud talking i
don't want to hear loud [ __ ] people i
didn't want him to hear we were talking
about that's so interesting i always
answered people and one answer questions
if you if you asked me a question that
would require more than a yes or no
you're not going to get an answer from
me when i was cooked up was this the
entire time you did it or towards the
end when you wanted to be alone this is
the last 10 or 15 years
in the beginning i didn't shut the [ __ ]
up and then you realize if you talk you
got to listen yeah so if you're going to
tell somebody an hour's story then you
got to put up with an hour with their
story
while they're holding on to the mirror
you know let me tell you what happened
you're like let me get the line all
right enough yeah
the dealer has the stories and you have
to listen to him to get the line i think
it's like fishing man
so it's it's really interesting that
and then you would bring women home yeah
and like i told them the great
fitzsimmons and we were here
that is painful because then they start
opening up about family and you want to
[ __ ] them in the ass and also they tell
you how they blew
the neighbor when they were eight
and they [ __ ] this and you you're like
i don't think i want you around yeah
yeah i never did coke with chicks around
here's the rule with me like i had a
girlfriend for seven years and i'd be on
these three four day benders and she
just figured i was out with women no man
i was doing dumb [ __ ] like bowling and
talking about rock and roll and watching
mtv
and it was new back then and vhs tapes
of like judas priest live or anything uh
no chicks around because coke would wipe
my dick out
like something and once you know it and
you're done with them yeah once you come
to terms that you're not going to get a
heart on yeah now you're going to sit
there she's gonna be naked for three
hours and you're gonna eat her [ __ ] and
get around the coke you know what
[ __ ] it how about we eliminate the
middleman let leave her at home i'll
stay in my room i'll jerk off maybe
watch a little porn maybe if it's
available something on showtime or
cinemax and go to sleep i did a lot of
dumb [ __ ] like yeah my dealer had
foosball
so it'd be like a six-hour foosball
tournament for hundreds of dollars you
know just
you know battling foods and your arms
all [ __ ] when you leave but you know
just hanging with dudes talking and
rocking and playing guitar and [ __ ] no
women around it was just coke fort so
what made you stop because joey
has a similar story he just stopped he
didn't go to rehab or anything yeah yeah
well i was my voice was starting to get
shot and i had three other guys in the
band and it was like
you know when you're the singer and
everybody's surviving you can't go up i
can't sing now nobody's paying bills
so you they're like what the [ __ ] are
you doing blow for when you know your
voice is going to be [ __ ] up you know
so
and and also i was describing the pain
to somebody of what like a bad throat
feels like like when you hear about
singers like adele or steven tyler
anybody where they get vocal notes
that's like calluses on your vocal cords
it feels like hundred pound weights on
your throat so you're like i got to get
rid of this you know so that is bummer
what happens when
the expression your voice goes let me
get a milk done over there let me see
what you got
like let's take an example chris cornell
yeah okay
i saw chris cornell early on i don't
know what year was and his voice sounded
great it was a small place right then i
saw him in 97 before i left seattle yeah
and it wasn't good and i'm like is this
the h is just the blow and then i saw
him on sign that live it's on youtube
though down on the upside yeah oh god
oh god his voice is bad and now
chris's voice is a little back yeah but
it's not all back he has to sing a
different style now
to
describe what happens what happens to
your voice
well you got to think about
when you're writing those tunes and
recording them you're 20
21 years old
you're not thinking when i'm 55
i'm going to be singing hands all over
you know how that is like
you know you're not thinking about that
you're thinking
i can sing high
and i'm going to [ __ ] show you guys i
can sing high though obviously they're
kind of zeppelin uh
sound you know uh
sabbath back then
and uh so you sing hi
you're not like like who thought brian
johnson was going to sing back in black
at 60 years old you're not thinking that
you know so you're in the studio and
you're singing and also you gotta
understand when you're in the studio
it's so [ __ ] easy to sing you got
phones on
you can hear everything perfect and
you're like becky and blair
hit the sad so glad to be back
how loud is your singing
now when you're in a [ __ ] arena and
it's crazy loud this is pre
uh in-ear monitors now most singers use
those you just have shitty speakers on
the floor and you're going over marshall
stacks that are like [ __ ] locomotives
and you're trying to sing on top of that
so your voice just gets trashed you know
and no sleep air conditioning buses
travel interviews over and over and over
smoke like the fake smoke you know that
[ __ ] oh i hate that stuff what does air
conditioning do because i used to work
on a tv show where the host would come
in to do uh voiceovers
and he he loved the
booth really cold but then i've heard a
lot of people like it really warm well
some people it dries out their throat
some people it doesn't but ac can dry
out your throat different you know
climates you know you can get into like
uh you can get into like arizona and
[ __ ]
and be you know all dry
you know wherever everything the problem
with singing is it's your body
guitar is too it's hands but that takes
years to go you know like you get carpal
tunnel or something but with singing
it's completely your body and and you
want to get up and running like the band
and party all night and talk and you
know and you can
if you're going to keep going i mean
these bands like acdc if you look at
their tour i'm back in black they played
like a solid year every [ __ ] day
there's no day off once that record hits
you don't get to go i need four days off
they go no man
it doesn't happen because there's too
much money lost on days off hotels tour
bus you know cruise everything and you
said you toured for four years straight
once three years yeah but that's van
stuff
and you're you can plot it out your own
way you know what i mean okay so it's on
every night it's every night but you're
not like
that's a larger scale
you know those guys could be doing three
interviews a day in the morning like
when we do comedy you gotta go do
morning radio imagine you got to do
morning radio then afternoon radio then
you go sound check then you do the gig
then maybe you got to get right on the
bus you don't sleep right away on the
bus you're wide awake jacked from the
gig and then you roll into town 6 a.m
back to radio some more radio a sound
check you know after a while you're like
[ __ ]
i'm tired right now from doing comedy
you know
and that's not even like
you know rock rock also you have mad
volume
[ __ ] is so [ __ ] loud on stage and
you're out there just trying to get
above it
very interesting what you said that when
you sing
it's your whole body i feel the same way
about [ __ ] comedy sometimes it's true
when i headline five shows oh friday
night when i go back to my room i'm
stiff
it's like i played in a football game
i'm gonna go back yeah
it's your whole [ __ ] body i feel my
toes holding onto the floor
i feel my spine in action my mind's
thinking i'm speaking at a certain
volume
it's it's really people think
you know i come home on sunday i have
a week you know i'm 51 i don't have
sundays in me i don't have a wednesday
in me yeah i don't i don't have that
show on wednesday a couple weeks ago i
got greedy when i was home a week
and i called and i got all these spots
yeah by sunday my blood pressure was 2
000 because i'm getting home at 12
staying up till one you're jacked 1 30
yep and then you're getting up at six
with the baby
and you're doing it all over again
you're writing you're doing a podcast
you're talking to this guy you're
talking to that guy it adds the [ __ ] up
yeah man when i go on the road now i try
to keep it light friday and saturday i
got two shows
i don't want to be walking around i
don't want to go to no [ __ ] events
yeah i don't want to do nothing because
i know that whatever i do is going to
take away from my show i'm going to be
tired i'm not going to sell a joke the
right way because my knee hurts
so i don't want that to happen
does the voice does the voice thing come
into effect because you scream you don't
scream but you're loud you're not a
quiet person on stage you know you're
breathing and you're thinking and that
requires [ __ ] calories and rest and
yeah that's amazing in the last month i
feel like i'm falling apart
it's weird and i've never felt like this
but i'm i'm working seven days a week
i'm 48
and in the last
seriously in the last month my knees
hurt but my brain i feel foggy lately
and i don't know what that is like i'm
just like a couple days off yeah
need to go get entertained you need to
go see judas priests wanting to see a
movie a couple movies
just watch some people walk by and fall
yeah your mind gets refueled your mind
gets refueled when you do the dumbest
[ __ ] yes i watch the movie in my hotel
room i i hate doing it but i did it 16
[ __ ] dollars yeah
but i did it because i know this is what
i need to be good at night yeah i need
to watch a couple law and orders i need
to take my mind off what i'm doing
you know if you ask a major league
baseball player before he has a game
what's he want to do he wants to do
something completely opposite in that
game
you want to listen to some music maybe
watch a tv show so now when it's time
your mind is pre perplexed and focused
and ready to [ __ ] blow up if you're
sitting there thinking about it you're
wasting that energy
you're burning energy if you're just
sitting there watching
the ufc yeah cheering for a fight with
your mind somewhere else it's so much
better for you at least this is what i
feel so do you have worse sets like when
you started out if you were going over
your set list and going over jokes when
i first started out until about 15 years
ago i hadn't figured it out
a great lady once told me on game shows
on game day i don't do dick before the
show really you don't want to go eat
dinner no
and i was like that's amazing she goes
and i thought about it and every time i
go meet people to eat dinner at six i'd
bomb the first show yeah not supposed to
be and then they're talking and then
they're asking you stupid questions so
tell us about l.a what's the auditioning
process and you're talking and you're
talking and you're talking and you're
talking that's not now you get on stage
and you're unfocused you didn't
entertain you were entertaining yeah
so when i go to dinner and you call me
up and go my family wants to take you
out to dinner i'm entertaining they're
asking me [ __ ] questions i wasn't
working with de niro how was it working
with adam sandler so i'm entertaining
yeah so now i gotta do three [ __ ]
shows so now the people who are paying
to see me i'm bombing in front of them
because i'm tired from talking with
these jerk cars for dinner about nothing
so what's your perfect day on the road
then perfect day on the road is on a
friday morning i get up i do a little
radio
i go back i get stoned i take a nap
right on the way to radio i might eat a
little breakfast maybe before i get a
little breakfast on the way back i get
stoned i don't want to do no [ __ ]
podcasts i don't want to do [ __ ]
yeah i get up at two o'clock i'm done
with podcasts when i leave here on
wednesday i'm done with podcasts okay
now then comes [ __ ] friday i get up
around two i go downstairs i eat lunch
somewhere very close
somewhere very close on the way back i
smoke a joint i drink a cup of coffee
now i have an hour to sit down and go
over my material for the night
go over maybe something i said to laugh
at you something i'll call you and go
what did i say the other night at the
store and you're telling me that's what
i'm doing my food's digesting so about 4
30 i go to the gym i ride the bike i
lift some [ __ ] weights i jump in the
pool you might steam and sauna
you're back upstairs by six o'clock now
you got an hour you're coming upstairs
you watch a little news maybe at 6 30
you go upstairs you wash your [ __ ]
seven o'clock you're ready to [ __ ] go
you sit there till 7 30 you take a cab
or they come get you
see that's it i don't want to see nobody
huh you don't eat dinner before a show
no i don't want to see nobody i don't
want to eat i don't know no i just meant
by yourself yeah by myself the whole
time
there's no reason to be talking
i'm sitting there i'm preparing i got
two [ __ ] shows i gotta go talk
entertain 250 [ __ ] people a show for
two shows minimum you think what am i
gonna do who do you wanna go talk to i
go do my two shows now friday for me is
a big night that's a big night i come
home i take sleeping pills
because i want to sleep 15 hours because
saturday night i'm not gonna sleep i'm
gonna get on that [ __ ] plane at five
in the [ __ ] morning and get the [ __ ]
out of there so my friday night there's
no partying there's no drinking there's
no nothing once the show's over i go
back i may get something i may not get
some feet more than likely i won't get
something to eat but i got a nice coffee
strong and i'll stay up till two and
right and go on my show and think of
what i said and what i thought of and
law and orders on or something stupid
and about two o'clock i take two [ __ ]
sleeping pills and i wanna sleep till
nine nine thirty ten i wanna get up eat
breakfast and if i'm lucky enough smoke
a joint come back and take another
[ __ ] nap till 1201
and the same thing i get up now today i
work out different i'll go to the pool
and swim
something again somewhere light you eat
dinner and you're in your room i'm
packing
by five o'clock i'm already packing so
when i leave at 7 30 when i come back at
12 nothing all i got to do in the
morning put my sleep apnea away
take a shower wash my [ __ ] drink cup of
coffee take my vitamins and go to the
airport
how would you describe the road road
because it's i know it's business for
you so you can't really look at it this
way but it sounds
i don't i don't know if it sounds mean
but just boring like like you like if
you were in a city you might want to go
see a baseball game or go i used to have
a lot of fun on the road yeah there was
a time when you went on the road with
your musicians you were new to it it was
fun you were slash that's right you
drink you snorting coke you going up
there
maybe you had your musical sets yeah
yeah maybe you didn't maybe but you're
going through growing pains my first 10
years on the road we're growing pains
we're learning
and you learn and you learn and you
learn and don't get me wrong until
seven years ago i would go on the road
to [ __ ] get high
i'm not gonna lie to you and tell you it
was nothing different but even then i
took care of myself a little bit
i didn't really get myself involved like
i didn't go to people's houses at the at
the club somebody brought me the blow
and run from the blow to the hotel room
yeah i don't go to people's houses no
houses no parties they're always trying
to get you to go there yes the house no
because then i wake up at six in the
morning i don't know where the [ __ ] i am
yeah they might get a strange city you
know no no see you guys tomorrow
again what do you want to do
i came to the show and i want to see
what you're staying with there's what's
going on i got a grandma blowing my body
but if you go back to the hotel as soon
as we get i'm gonna put you to work i
have a boyfriend and stay here and wait
for your [ __ ] boyfriend i'll go home
and jerk off by myself
it's that simple that's what it used to
be
and i learned a lot going on the road
with joe joe would call me but you want
to go work out what jobs what are you
talking about bye click hang up
[ __ ] workout i'm on the road we'll
work out i'm about to order the three to
three fire macaroni and cheese
i'm gonna get myself pastrami sandwich
and a milkshake you want to go [ __ ]
work out what the [ __ ] just a [ __ ]
death machine and then they used to go
on then they used to go on the road at
first and used to be a lot of us
and i didn't like that i never liked
that i don't like boys bands i don't
like six people hanging out but that's
the way it was and then i i raised my
hand and he went on tour and then it
changed
i didn't like that i didn't like getting
up at one they always wanted to go to a
[ __ ] mall yeah what am i [ __ ] uh
16 yeah you know rogan and paige daddy
let's go to a mall
what the [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] mall so people like
that's the guy from fairfax and five
guys are standing around
[ __ ] you in the [ __ ] wall i'm gonna
go no [ __ ] mall
so i stopped going to mall with those
[ __ ]
and i learned that the least i was
[ __ ] around the daytime and the more
i was by myself and in my head the
better i would do at night yeah the more
i was and you know when you're in your
head i love lee i love when lee goes on
the road with me but i don't i never see
him i don't want nobody in the room yeah
yeah i'm on the road and i leave on
thursday as much as i like your team you
need the money you want me to take out
thank you but i got to be honest with
you yeah
i i don't want to see nobody i don't
know what the [ __ ] you doing in the
daytime man i don't know i never museum
i went out with bobby lee i never saw
him once no i don't want to do nothing
and i never even took because i didn't
the one like whenever i go to show i
don't want to be in the way just but i
know you like talking in the green room
and stuff but like when we went to
austin
i i never called you fly like i didn't
know what you i knew kind of what your
process was but people
would text me and be like how's the road
i'm like i'm watching tv i went and
walked around the area for a second but
i never like i didn't expect us to be
hanging out all day like i just i
thought that would have been weird
it's just something i got over yeah and
as you move along you realize that
it's a waste of your energy i'm about to
do two shows people [ __ ] paid to come
see me
well what it is too is your life
what people don't understand is for
about six hours of your life you're in
front of about five to a thousand people
strangers and you're on just oh yeah
thanks man oh yeah thanks so much thanks
for coming check my channel
everything so then the second i'm done i
run to the room
and just chill decompress
all the way to the bottom just like shoe
man and and if i don't grab these
personal times i'm gonna run out of gas
you know what i mean like oh i shouldn't
have [ __ ]
told that but that's my problem
sometimes a guy will be like hey man i
know you're good with ebay can you maybe
help me with this or hey can you get my
car fixed because i know all kinds of
people and then i get into that and then
i go [ __ ]
i need a nap and i'm [ __ ] here you
know whatever not not just on the road
but in town or whatever yeah and i'm
doing three four spots a night in town
and i'm going [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] here i
didn't get any sleep today i gotta have
sleep man it's weird i'm 48 but i feel
90 because i'm working seven days a week
even with rock you didn't work seven
days a week you didn't work like four or
five and you know it's different you got
different you're out i see you you're at
the left back right here and that's what
it takes that's what a lot of these guys
don't think when you first get to l.a or
you're first moving around here it's
like what they tell you when you go to i
get out of a rehab listen you have a
rehab you gotta go to a meeting every
day for six months yeah but listen it's
not gonna work out for you yeah if you
don't go to a meeting every day for six
months and that's the first 90 days
after that i need for you to go to three
[ __ ] meetings a day yeah and that's
when people crack
people don't know that dedication people
don't know you know when i got here
from 97 to 2005
i went out every night those 17 weeks i
was in the longest yard was the first
time i wasn't out every night because i
was in new mexico i was out every night
guys i hosted on sunday nights yeah you
did the open mic on monday you did
tuesday because it was fat tuesday
before
people in the original
and then before that i needed my coke
money i'd be a felipes i'd be at flies
i'd be all over [ __ ] town doing these
mexican rooms yeah because they made you
better by the time i got to the store i
was going to kill those [ __ ]
because i just did two mexican rooms
where they're [ __ ] not even paying
attention to me yeah you know i had to
follow jeff garcia or something it's
amazing so
i was out every night then one day i go
you know what
it's starting to it's i got to do
something you got to pick your battles
and you have to make the scheduling but
there's one point in your career here
where you're here the first three or
four years you're right every night i
didn't know nothing about not in about i
wasn't gonna rest is that my t my show
is on tonight portland here no
you watch portland we have a friend that
lives in movie
what's his career do
you got no time for movies there's no
breaking bad in your life there's no dvr
when i get home at night i'm i used to
go i used to get the backstage when i
first got here yeah backstage was huge
then if you want to act this was your
way in because agents wouldn't sign you
without a real
they didn't care what was on that reel
so you'd have to use college films so i
would buy backstage on the way home i
would stop at uh curson yeah yeah get
the backstage backstage there at 12 and
i go home on thursday on wednesday night
thursday morning and i fill out
envelopes all night and auditions and
lick letters and hand write i want to be
in your movie and send them so i would
get the fur because on those movies and
now no budgets they only look at 10
people so i always wanted to get my foot
in the door with this i'd be up till
four licking on envelopes doing blow
yeah and i'd be licking them at the same
time yeah and then you get up and it's
the same you're meeting people to write
and but i didn't you know i was telling
somebody i threw my fitness away yeah
when i first moved here i was i was 240.
i went up to 300 pounds yeah in six
months
because everything was
comedy
it wasn't that i didn't take care of
myself that was i gave my life for this
that's what i got ozzy osbourne sold
your soul for rock and roll you want to
[ __ ] own comedy you want to own an
artist you want to be a musician you
want to be a banker a plumber carpenter
first five years you gotta [ __ ] own
it
you gotta [ __ ] own it you gotta get
in there well i can't work thanksgiving
night because my [ __ ] your [ __ ]
family [ __ ] your [ __ ] family yeah
you're the second guy if you work
thanksgiving you might [ __ ] get a
bump the guy will see you that's how you
move up well i've been here for three
years well worth [ __ ] thanksgiving
you gotta work what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
that's what what as soon as the comic
tells me
yeah things aren't happening i guess you
gotta be gay to make it in hollywood
yeah what you do next weekend i'm going
to my brother's wedding you know what
i'm doing i'm doing nine spots in town
that's why nothing's happening for you
yeah because they come out and it's a
[ __ ] jokey joke let's go to the
improv and hang they know hanging yeah
they're no hanging dog if you ain't
getting on stage they don't hang it why
are you gonna go down and hang and talk
to who you hang on stage once you hang
on stage you give your goodbyes you get
your free dinner when you're broke
because when you're broke and they give
you a free cheeseburger you take that
you know
i ate one last night there yeah that's
the point of doing the spot there
absolutely just to get your [ __ ] free
meal that's all comes with it when i'm
doing an improv i don't spend money the
whole day i i just starve it out till i
get there that's what a [ __ ] comic
does yeah because i know i go okay i'm
gonna eat i can eat as much as i want
there when you walk into the comedy
store the cherries [ __ ] flinch if you
if you walk by the bar and the cherries
are like i'm going down yeah you're a
real [ __ ] comic you understand
i heard a great thing uh from a buddy of
mine he said uh
uh jaymore said that uh jay leno said
they said hey man how'd you get like
somewhere uh at the comedy store back in
the day and he said there was four
comedians
in line always first one got out of line
for a drink the next one got out of line
for a joint the next one got out of line
for [ __ ] and i stepped on stage
and it was an amazing uh scenario you
know because that's
i when i'm at the places i'm not there
to party
and i'm not there to uh you know seek
out anything except stage time well that
comes with asian experience right right
you shift right through the [ __ ]
right while they come in like let's do a
drink and i'll be right back let's get
two drinks get a jack and coke too and
i'm gonna call for heroin we're gonna go
back cut this [ __ ] [ __ ] you just
keep walking yeah just keep walking
that's a great job get the [ __ ] out of
here you get in your car and you go to
the next thing you do another spot and
there's always the people they're going
to be hanging out you know
and what the [ __ ] yeah go take care of
your business first then come back yeah
that was my motto i went and took care
of business first then i snorted coke
and i got my dick sucked and i looked
out windows but i went and did my two or
three spots first
yeah you can do anything after you've
worked after you work you do whatever
the [ __ ] you want the thing your
conscious is clear i did what i had to
do
that's why they call it work because
nobody wants to [ __ ] do it you know
what i'm saying how did you get into
music how old were you now you're from
the bay area yeah i got it originally i
got into music when i was uh you know i
used to work at rockin robins really at
san francisco in 1985. wow what's rockin
robin's it was a bar rock and roll bar
that the the lights cadillacs were all
up in the wall grills yeah and the
lights would go on and did they sing in
there the waiters
it was a 50s bar right yeah something
weird i worked on mondays
as a doorman did you live in the city i
lived in the tenderloin in 1985. did you
do comedy there not at all i didn't even
i was robbing people yeah i was cashing
in on travellers checks in japan town
for the cubans i was
i was a bodyguard i was selling blow i
did
excuse me i did everything
in fact the other night i read something
i told people on stage that
i looked everywhere bad and one of the
worst places badass
in the end there was an article saturday
uh a bunch of guys were heckling the
chick
the guy stuck up for his girlfriend they
stabbed them nine times don't [ __ ]
around to tend the line let me tell you
something the
tenderloin not quite gonna
i was just there because we were doing
the warfield and that's the ground zero
turk street and all that in there it's
uh
it's the ground zero of just
ghetto
and and here we're talking about a city
where a studio costs 2 200 bucks right
now you know what i mean
but they'll never
and i mean never be able to charge good
money for the tenderloin because the
roaches and the the [ __ ] stench and
the death in there is never gonna leave
so they're not trying to gentrify it
oh i'm sure they've tried but they just
what are you gonna do
original joe's was right there it just
burned down
that's one that blacked out that was the
great one they reopened down in north
beach which is great but that original
joe's was fire those waiters had the
[ __ ] outfits on dog it was straight
up gangsta i had a guy mr chow i always
had a chinese waiter in there
and i get the [ __ ] rusty nails i get
rusty irishman the [ __ ] do you know
when you're going to san jose next year
already july of course there's one right
there right there right there next to
the face
i went there one weekend two years ago
and i think you went there like five
times we went for breakfast once yeah
you looked up online what time they
opened and we planned the walk so we'd
get there right as they opened the door
and there was already a line right there
like 10 30 or less the slim joe burger
they got the joe burger then they had
the slim joe or the joe jr and it was on
a baguette oh fresh cut it in half
oh they put mayonnaise on their burgers
and i usually don't like mayonnaise on
my [ __ ] burgers they got that sidebar
there that was like straight out of
bukowski or you know bar fly yeah at a
bar there you just sit in there watch
the 49ers play you know i used to have
this uh group of friends i hung out with
when we turned 30 we had the dirty 30
and we would meet at original joe's and
drink on uh in that back room and eat in
san jose no at the san francisco oh down
right now right now
yeah i seen a guy stabbed in front of
there one time bleeding dead begging for
people to help you walked right into
original right
man you just step over that's standard
standard uh you know routine down there
i can't help you that spaghetti's
calling my name i just moved from new
york
and i was going in there to get my
spaghetti fixed every [ __ ] day for
lunch it's so good i would wake up
knowing that i had to go out and hustle
50 for lunch just to go to original
joe's like a doctor as long as i had a
meatball
i'm good to [ __ ] go i don't need
spaghetti with this and that all you
[ __ ] morons that ruin your spaghetti
i need spaghetti and two [ __ ]
meatballs and a piece of bread and some
butter
that's it yeah you know who's got a mean
spaghetti jones eat this santa monica on
santa monica and like uh berea
he's killer jones that's the rock and
roll it's it's been there like for 25 30
years but the jukebox has the best metal
like you're in there they're playing
motorhead they have a wall of jack
daniels bottles
and then it's all rock and roll and then
they serve spaghetti and a skillet comes
out [ __ ] just cooking and it's killer
man the sauce is kind of spicy two big
meatballs and you're listening to
motorhead meanwhile you take a train
down these [ __ ] french food no you
gotta eat at this place
i go there
i go there like once a week jones it's
on santa monica by that target and that
best buy right there yeah oh for most of
cafes across the street from it so it's
right there right now the wheat store
then they used to be able to yeah there
was a weed store
right there yeah yeah you know me i'm
better than [ __ ] weed maps
yeah
was i say to you uh so you started in
san francisco
what was cracking up there then what
kind of music was on fire i mean that's
sam that's santana that's a [ __ ]
beautiful area but what was cracking for
you what made you pick up the guitar the
microphone or the drums what was it well
i mean it's the bands that you're
listening to but then there's uh big
club bands at the time that
the club that was the ground zero for
san fran was called the stone it was on
412 broadway it was on broadway and
cross street was the mabuway gardens
that was the cbgb's of the west coast
and those two clubs had all the rock and
all the punk
and everyone played them you know
everyone from [ __ ] you know devo dead
kennedy's uh jerry garcia slayer kiss
everybody you know played those two
rooms
and i would just hang there every
[ __ ] day it was like my it was my
comedy store now you know my workshop
and uh
there was big club bands that nobody
knew but they were stars to me bands
local bands that were selling it out
like vicious rumors or or
road runner this ban lemons all these
bands when i was growing up
and then metallica came in you know and
it became metallica and exodus and laws
rocket and and all this metal testament
and really it was like once metallica
started hitting i was like wow this is
[ __ ] great what are we doing for a
living then
i uh i had well i did
construction which was the [ __ ] worst
you know you got to get up at like six
and i was like that wasn't like i was a
labor you know carrying [ __ ] wood up
i did that for a while then i painted i
moved on to painting houses
and then i got into booking the stone as
i was like
i don't know maybe 20
and i started booking the club because i
knew all the bands so i was helping them
like you got to get this band or that
band they're like well why don't you
book the weeknights
and
and that's really where i got my
knowledge of business
you know which help now with comedy i
understand booking i understand agencies
i understand commissions deals all that
paperwork and everything deposits i
learned it all as a kid
so it helped me as i played rock i just
managed the band myself because i
already knew all the scams and deals and
and how it worked you know and also when
a great band came my band opened because
i booked myself on it you know what i
mean so it was a great um it was great
learning experience
we talk a lot about some people don't
want to start from the bottom
yeah it's pretty cool that a lot of
musicians might not i don't want to work
at the club and i i'm a musician it's
pretty cool that you went and you
learned and and it helped you out like
some people wouldn't want to do that job
you know i i think the thing was to me
it was like it was a record store or
that if you could or a guitar center if
you could be around rock and music
yeah we're talking about this isn't now
where you go to chipotle and [ __ ] got
tattoos on their necks
and and hands
and you know back then if you had even
one tattoo you'd have to hide it
for a regular job
you couldn't have long hair you'd have
to put it up in a hat you know
now you just look [ __ ] you look like a
garbage can and work at chipotle i mean
you know like i always say i don't think
i got enough tattoos to work at chipotle
and i'm covered in them so whenever you
could get a job where you could say
this is how i look and i'm going to be
gone maybe a couple days a week
instantly to do a gig that's the kind of
gig you're looking for you know because
you gotta you gotta make some money
you're not making any money in your band
when you're starting
you know and that's not what it's about
anyway
you know that's why a lot of rockers
back then painted or did construction
because it didn't matter what you looked
like out there there's a company out
here that's called rock and roll movers
yeah and they're just in a band and they
move that's it i've seen them i've seen
them whatever you could do back then and
get away with your look you gotta
understand hair down to your ass
and tattoos no one's hiring you
you know what i mean what are you gonna
do like work as a waiter people go who
is that criminal
i mean that was actually a criminal look
sideburns you know i looked like neil
young for a big old mutton chops and
straight here like like a greg almond
you know
you're not getting a regular job like
that but you got to work but also you
didn't have to work that much because
rent was like a dollar in the city
back then no one wanted to live in the
city they wanted to live in marin
or walnut creek the city was blue collar
and dirty you know so all the artists
lived in the city and rockers and
painters it was [ __ ] fantastic
now all the rich people want to live in
the city you know because it's like oh
it's you know it's multicultural and
i've got a cappuccino yeah yeah it's
it's this is our city and it's like [ __ ]
man you wanted marin go back over there
it's crazy man i remember living in an
amazing apartment for 275 and i had a
garage
in san fran that's like [ __ ] 275 man
i lived at the virginian hotel
which is now the hostel the hostile
nintendo wine right there across from
the hilton yeah yeah yeah oh i know that
the alexander hotel that's the first
hotel i robbed i mean it's [ __ ] crazy
i was a
full-blown criminal in san francisco my
first apprenticeship
being out of jersey
what was the first band you were in
first band i was in this is an amazing
story i told it somewhere else but i was
in a band
with four buddies
i was in high school still they were two
years out
started this band and we named it warren
because
me and the other guy always had warrants
like you know run a stop sign you get a
ticket you just [ __ ] that thing you got
a warrant you got a warrant you know
[ __ ] speeding see you later i'm not
paying that [ __ ] i ain't got no money
and then you know there'd be that tail
light out you didn't know about and
get pulled over and there you go bye-bye
[ __ ] warrant
sitting down there at 850 bryant san
francisco going [ __ ]
so we get the band together and my mom's
like you guys should be called warren
you know my mom she was like you guys
all have warrants always it's a great
name we're like that is a great name
my mom was smart enough
to copyright the name
in
sacramento you could copyright it for
like 100 bucks you own the name
and a few years later that band warrant
got big and they came in knocking
you know they were like hey uh
their warriors call and said we tracked
you down
this pre-internet or [ __ ] cell phones
and they're like we we want to buy the
name we'll give you 750 or whatever and
we're like no because we were getting
big we don't want to give up our name
that's like starting over
you know you can't be like you know the
ding dongs formally worn it's just
starting over it just looks hokey and we
were on a [ __ ] roll
then they called about a month later
we'll give you 2 000.
and it was me and my buddy where
partners were like nah
it's not worth it 2000. we're broke
right
and then we don't hear from like six
months
and they're like they call and they go
we'll give you ten thousand last offer
we said no
and then they go all right twenty
immediately we go okay
and we uh sold him the name
it was funny about
seven years ago i was in vegas
uh seeing metallica new year's eve and i
didn't want to get a room so i just
stayed up all night and then caught the
first flight out and i'm sitting there
on this couch and here comes this guy's
look at him like i know this guy
he sits right by me i can't believe it's
janie laying the singer of warren he
recently passed away a few years back in
the hotel right up here right yeah
exactly he sits behind me and we've
never met
i mean this is [ __ ] creepy right
there it's like
out of nowhere a guy sitting next to me
i said hey man uh
i sold that bad name to you
and he goes oh [ __ ] man i always hated
that [ __ ] name i can't believe i'm
meeting you man i go i know right right
here he goes yeah i wanted to call it
lane like lane street or something
because he came into the band later but
they were big under warrant and the
label wouldn't do it because i hated it
and then we paid you guys
came out of our pockets i was like hey
man sorry brother and he's all good
let's go watch a game he was ending like
a
a college team he wanted me to go see
when we landed i was like see you man it
was weird and then he was dead like a
year later or something strange though
how you meet someone later right
that's weird how that you tell him and
you're talented i tell them that about a
year ago i bumped into ice cube iced tea
which one yeah just a really good rapper
ice cube
not the uh the guy in law order now yeah
the guy in law and order oh that's iced
tea i see an ice cube i opened for ice
cube yeah in 1995 in boulder for a
hundred bucks i would go to the fox
theater and torment them and say my name
is joey diaz that's a great theater i
had [ __ ] eight minutes of material
yeah i would go torment them i got 20
minutes i want to open up for somebody
they go all right all right whatever
we'll call you one day they [ __ ]
called and like whenever you open up ice
cream plant you take 100 right yeah
i went up there and [ __ ] bombed so
bad
they were [ __ ] but they had weed and
yeah oh it was terrible and you know
dude that's a year ago i seen him and i
go i don't know if you remember me i
opened for you and bold he goes
yeah you were pretty bad back then we
were [ __ ] laughing our [ __ ]
because i remember you were embarrassed
you came back there and [ __ ] i was
you know what do you do but
life's weird right like i worshiped nwa
growing up i saw ice cube three
different times and i mean he was my god
when i was a kid and i did a movie with
him five years ago
and i couldn't [ __ ] believe the first
day on the set he comes walking up he's
like hey how's it going i was like
that's [ __ ] ice cube right there you
know straight outta compton crazy
[ __ ] name ice cube from a gang
called [ __ ] with attitude you know
what i mean you're like man that's him
it's crazy to do a movie
with a guy that you i mean who thought
20 years ago i'm gonna be
sitting you know doing a football movie
with him
it's so bizarre right it works uh when i
got here i got to meet james coburn i
did a movie with james corbin and arless
and i thought my life was it that was it
you know and then i did something with
dick van dyke
who was when i came from cuba that's how
i learned to speak the language and i
couldn't i kept talking to his son he
goes why are your eyes watering up
and i kept saying i can't look at your
dad and i told dick van dyke's son the
story and he went and got him and goes
come here tell my dad and while i'm
telling dave van dyke the story i'm just
crying
i'm just bawling i'm just like you have
no idea what this means to me when i
don't have that plan in cuba i'd watch
your show every [ __ ] morning
and here i am yeah with you oh my
[ __ ] god are you kidding me if my
mother was alive would have her on the
phone lighting candles and [ __ ]
it's crazy it really is that you look up
to people and you bump into them years
later i see you know i've been wanting
to go see pat benatar yeah i was a big
pat benatar fan every time she's in town
i'm out of town but i would love to go
up to the canyon club and see them and
then afterward tell her how i [ __ ]
mailed a thousand postcards when she
married the guitar mtv did a contest to
go to hawaii to pat benatar's wedding
and i was so deranged at that at 18 19.
really i thought i was going to win the
wedding that's a step i'm not a guest
i wrote postcards for a week i thought i
had it locked in i love that hell is for
children right oh that whole hour
pat benatar's crime of passion awesome
and the second one the the second one
the third one a [ __ ] his guitar work
is
tremendous that guy's great but her too
like um
you better run is that it you better
hide the video with her with the white
and black t-shirt on that's it you
better run through the white black
t-shirt oh
so hot man
yeah that was my first band and
you know you just kind of
you're gigging and you're rocking you're
playing keg parties and [ __ ] and
you're learning
it's funny to think about like where i
am now
in life was all because of that back
then yeah
all that's like getting you ready for
today that's it man
keg parties you know whatever whatever
it was a [ __ ]
you know high school how similar are the
businesses
comedy
music business is a complete robbery
yeah now because of the stealing and
stuff let me tell you i did that movie
with ice cube
the day i got home
there were checks in my mailbox
from the movie
you try to get music money
forget it
it would come four times a year and that
was only if you had some guy that could
[ __ ] hound down your money or else
you just played free
it's always been like that
you know what i mean like hey where's
our royalties um
we sent them out
no you didn't
well we'll go to accounting and we'll
call you back and then you know months
later where's our money
movies it would blew my mind because
each week you're working on the monday
the [ __ ] checks in there
so i was like this is incredible there's
actually money here
i mean they i have no manager no agent
they could easily just said thanks man
what am i going to do
you know what i mean everyone would do
their first 10 movies free
you know what i mean a movie with ice
cube they go hey you want to do it free
you go yeah [ __ ] yeah i want to do free
the music stories i have heard
have been just mind-boggling black
sabbath not getting checks you know rudy
sarso was here last week talking about
it how yeah you know you want oh you
want money [ __ ] we ate all the muffins
i guess we have to start a [ __ ]
kick
[ __ ] edibles on fire
how are you feeling buddy i'm pretty
[ __ ] stoned yeah [ __ ] yeah you know
the music stories i've heard are just
you know uh the guy from ccr yeah oh
yeah rob you know ozzy i mean just just
you know i remember years ago
talking to somebody who was opening up
for uh
somebody like you like 10 years ago he
lived in the building with it this kid
didn't even have money for rent and i
asked him
i go you're on a tour with
jane's addiction
aren't you making money because no we're
paying back the first album yeah oh yeah
they're taking all the money for the
first dollar well we talked i talked
about i talk about it a lot on my
podcast
it's a loan
you sign a record deal and rudy sarso
and i were talking about how [ __ ]
funny this is it's the only loan that
when you pay back
you don't own it still
so they loan you the money to make the
record
say they loan you 250 000
you have to pay that back then once you
pay it back you start getting residuals
you know royalties from your record
but you don't own your record which is
hilarious so what's the point of an
album then if they don't pay for
recording costs isn't that the point of
well your your point is you hope it
sells so you can go out on the road and
sell t-shirts and tickets and make money
from t-shirts and tickets you know shirt
cost you two dollars to make these
[ __ ] are selling them for like 65 you
know 55 bucks a t-shirt anyway
you don't own the records so you're so
you're locked into a seven album deal
it's three for sure unless they don't
like you if your first record doesn't
sell they just drop you
but if it does sell you're locked into
them for seven you know or three
whatever you signed
and uh it's all alone always
so the genius of these bands that made
it through like metallica and
soundgarden and and
jack white and josh you know from queens
all these guys now they can put their
own records out
because they have a a draw that'll buy
them and they're making way more money
than they did when they were on a record
label you know on a big record label so
how does you two give their cd away to
everybody with itunes
well youtube is at a situation where
nobody's buying records they know it so
they're like it backfired on them but
they thought this will make us look like
heroes
we're you too the big money machine
we're gonna give you our record
but then the way they did it nobody
liked it because it felt like you know
you invaded my phone which i i
understand
but what it really did was open your
eyes to like anybody can just go into
your phone shows how much access they
have to yeah of course if you think you
have anything
uh that's not
accessed like your internet or your
[ __ ] anytime you click on porn they
could just blue whatever i mean every
i mean there's so many people nobody
cares what you're doing unless it's a
serious crime but you know that's why it
backfired on them you know
and also i didn't think the record was
that good that's that was the biggest
complaint you put shitty music in my
[ __ ] mailbox
you can't put [ __ ] in my mailbox it's
going to be good put a picture some
[ __ ] in there something you're not
going to show up with bad [ __ ] music
you know what i've been awesome if they
would have sent you their library
here's all our records and by the way
the new ones in there too
they would have looked like they were
[ __ ] kings they were really sold they
already made the money they're gonna
make you would have got octon baby you
would have got joshua tree you would
have got uh unforgettable fire or
whatever could you imagine if they did
that here's our catalog thank you for
being our fans for years you would have
just been like [ __ ] what a bunch of
kings you know what i mean
and then you would have got the new one
you wouldn't have said anything you
already got oh and i got the new one
it's not bad
you know i was a big music fan growing
up it's all you have yeah
for certain people it's all you have and
i went to everything i went to
james brown i went to all john was pat
benatar i went to see uh tom petty with
with the chick from [ __ ] fleet with
mac yeah in 83.
i went to all this [ __ ] as a kid and i
believed in it you know and they too
and then you hear all this [ __ ] and then
i'm still a fan i mean it doesn't make a
a difference to me but then you get in
this business here and it's like you
look behind the curtain a little bit
yeah now you understand the stories
you know you understand don arden
telling his daughter that ozzy osborne's
dead he's worthless he's a piece of [ __ ]
we've already robbed him for everything
i mean they robbed that you know left
him in the sunset marquis to die sunset
marquita died and i did a when i first
got here my first real job was a video
for
john fogany yeah i got it at the comedy
stores i was walking out when he wanted
a couple tough looking guys
i went to the next days with director of
barbed wire and i got to sit at lunch
with john furrier didn't bother him
and he just was talking to everybody and
that was the the whole thing that he
didn't get any residuals for all those
songs with ccr something [ __ ]
outrageous like you sit there and go
what are you saying guy took all his
money he owned fantasy records he's the
guy that did the godfather soundtrack
and that was the big war
with his brother his name was sal's van
zant sales van zann i think there's a
song that uh fogarty did
i don't dance for sal or something
but his brother died of aids
and on his death bed
him and his brother never talked again
because he took the side of sal sal's
vans and whatever and so on his death
bed fogarty said [ __ ] it i'm gonna go
see him
i gotta [ __ ] end this
and he went to his death then and his
brother said i'm still on sal's side and
he just said oh
[ __ ] i just walked out you know
can you believe that man that's a that's
an interesting story man i think the
main problem is when you're [ __ ]
hungry and a guy comes along and says
you want to make records and be famous
you sign anything
and then
because you're thinking you're signing
away nothing who cares i got nothing now
i'm going to go into the studio and make
a record have you ever signed anything
bad i didn't i got lucky because
over the years of years of stories
i was pretty like sharp on it i wasn't i
wasn't like the cocaine guy like yeah
rock and roll and just sign anything i
was like yeah rock and roll but let's
look at this for a minute
you know what i mean
so
and also i never met sold enough records
to know about getting ripped off you
have to get to a level first
to get ripped off you know how many bad
sign deals and didn't do anything you
know what i'm saying they're not going
to get ripped up there's nothing there
you have to get to a big level and then
you get ripped off
you know the music industry also gave me
the dream to dream to be a comic because
you read about you know atlantis
morissette putting out now and it dies
and then you know you read about the
sheryl crows putting that now and the
hound dies in the record label dumps her
and she moves to vegas and starts
jamming with some guys and we got cheryl
crowe back on the [ __ ] map you know i
remember seeing sheryl crow doing a free
concert in boulder opening up for like
local guys bands in the area
and six months later
next you know she was [ __ ] headlining
or theaters you know
you know all i want to do is have some
fun it was amazing i saw it i saw it
i saw her in march and then in october
there she is
[ __ ] at the fox theater headlining it
for yeah you know that's how quick you
know so that little dream from music
you know ozzy osbourne was
dead he hooks up with randy rhodes the
first time as
it's a [ __ ] monster i'm there april
12th at the palladium with my buddies
yeah and so you you learn that's
listening to those stories
always
uh kept my dream alive for comedy i
think that was the main reason that
helped me stick it out
you hear about all those you know
singers that are dead and
you know joe lynn turner yeah joe
linguido whatever his real name is
what's up lee you're all [ __ ] up
where's tony bennett cox oh [ __ ] you're
slipping you didn't play about it last
week
the church of what's happening now
monday night with dean delray a
beautiful [ __ ] monday night
a little tony bennett for you
[ __ ]
slow things down a little bit
oh [ __ ] lee look at the shape you're
gonna eat this [ __ ] last piece no not
even high [ __ ]
don't be silly you're not even high i
told you that's a new chef
well he's putting the same amount of
weed in it
keeping well it's beautiful today
where do i piss
right there we'll split this last piece
left
now people know where our bathrooms are
how's that candy bunny
which one
i don't know i like kitkat but i haven't
had malted balls for a while
come on balls
let me give some shout outs here with my
main man who's taking a piss there
i love you guys garrett richardson thank
you very much for the card uh i'm mental
i was gonna bring in a reader for lee
but
i forgot it cleo happy birthday happy
birthday cleo i'm happy you enjoyed your
present uh somebody hit me up a couple
days ago and said
they want to give cleo something nice it
was a gofund me account and uh lee and i
donate a little something to church and
uh
we're family so this is how we do it
cleo we love you don
don
thank you again for the con don son
thank you for the kind words i hope your
chinese are japanese i don't know what
the [ __ ] you are but you made sense
kareem ismail
sean toner i love you [ __ ] bobby
charoon
and tony b ferguson
i hope the piece is on i hope no black
people are jumping up and down i hope a
lot of [ __ ] ain't going on in fergus how
was that be okay
it was awesome
sometimes you gotta let that [ __ ]
spout open up and [ __ ] crack relax
what's weird is i can drink about a
thousand iced teas and not have to piss
but water cleans you right the [ __ ] out
yeah that's what you're supposed to do
it's a natural [ __ ]
so what was the band that you went on
tour with other bands with that's this
one here blacktop yeah
it was a combination of two-lane
blacktop and then my solo career dean
del rey
that record right there you were talking
about sheryl crow
linda perry signed me
signed the band
to interscope from foreign on blondes
who now
you know she wrote some of the biggest
songs for pink
and christina aguilera but remember she
had that what's going on yeah yeah yeah
so that's her label there rockstar
records
and we did a record with bill betrell
who did those sheryl crow first two
records
and then the band disintegrated i went
solo and from there on
uh just played non-stop
uh
rock and roll man like springsteen style
black crows
that kind of music you know ac dc you
got a tattoo a bonsai you didn't do a
little soul strip or nothing when i was
young i did a tribute to bonn every year
on the day he died called the church of
bonscott
every year
do entire uh ac dc run
uh every year but that would be pretty
much my ac dc
uh early on i would play one song a gig
you know usually it was jailbreak
you know going to make a cheese that's a
great one right last week i played with
marin
at the baked potato remember i told you
to come
and i did let to be rock
with the band that was awesome awesome
first time i sang with the band in years
since i started comedy
five six six six seven years you know
what's one of my all-time favorite
albums is power range yeah that's a
great one of my all-time favorite
[ __ ] albums i just i always steal
from radio stations i respect when they
leave me in the room for a while i see
they got
ac dc they got powerades it's going home
with papa
i love let that be rock the highway the
hell
uh you know
people just don't get it people just
this new generation of life just doesn't
get it yeah to me walk all over you and
touch too much
bon scott is just sensational but
uh angus [ __ ] takes over i mean just
that yeah
power rage you know i remember we were
talking about things from england
because the first ac dc album
came in two different albums yeah you
know so the the american one doesn't
have soul stripper on it it only came
out in australia or the uk
so we would have to go up there that's
what we were talking about rudy rudy's
good friends with them right it's where
in jersey where we're from rudy's went
to memorial
so there's a store things from england
and i went there
he i could call him and say i need two
tickets for ozzie and he would get me
the two tickets so you pay them a vig
whatever the [ __ ] it was but
uh i just love everything ac dc do i
like brian johnson
i tolerate back in black right uh i
don't like listening to it anymore
because you had to be around in 1980 i
was i heard that album at every party
that was it there was a time where every
place you went
down
there
when i'm listening to a radio and i hear
back in black for two minutes i get
happy then i switch it yeah you want to
impress me [ __ ] put on uh problem child
put it on
put on squealer put on [ __ ] rock and
roll dalmatian anything but that [ __ ]
back and black and for those who suck
the [ __ ] we salute you again i shop with
it now i'm from pathmark
i love that record you know i like like
two songs it was funny because i out
once i started doing my thing when i was
like 19 i got less and less
into the concerts but i saw everybody i
seen the scorpions and rainbow yeah i
saw the scorpions
was it with rainbow the one year in 82
blackout on the blackout background i
saw that tour but jovi opened when i was
live yeah like a 7 800 fahrenheit or
whatever his uh first record yeah they
had that um
runaway yeah ooh she's a little red
yeah that they opened on that never saw
bon jovi wow i've seen him three times
it's funny because
jovi
gets a lot of flack and stuff but um
you know [ __ ] man those songs he wrote a
lot of songs you know what i mean and
he's kind of like a survivor you know he
took some [ __ ] job as a janitor at the
studio and then tracked at night in it
and wrote that runaway song and and then
[ __ ] came out and and worked it you
know and
it's funny when you're on the road like
you and you go to these towns or i've
been all around the world you go to
these cities like where def leppard's
from or jovi and you're like
hey man these [ __ ] guys came out of
here
you know what i mean like how
like when i go to sheffield england and
think def leppard was in this old [ __ ]
steel town
and they played russia where's judah's
priesthood the same place for sabbath
yeah same thing you know
birmingham birmingham yeah and they
describe those places and then you go
even right now
if you go to [ __ ] birmingham you're
like this place is a dump
you know they got out of here and they
[ __ ] made it man we're not talking
about a band that started in new york or
l.a we're talking about some [ __ ]
toenail
on the continent and they got out it's
so weird to me you know when you're when
you're at when you play the stone pony
and you go this is like bruce land right
here
you know and you're in asbury park
and it's like an old [ __ ] run down
amusement park that's gone with a faded
peewee golf there it's [ __ ] crazy
it's crazy and there's nothing there it
looks like atomic
bomb went off except stone pony and then
a couple things you go
wait this is asbury park i only went to
the stone pony one time but i used to go
to the asbury park convention center
yeah i think i saw a priest there one
time
that place right there on the wall oh
yeah this is great right jim florentine
tells a great story on metal major
tobacco i want to see leopard there and
i went to that concert
for a while you would go to concerts
somebody always light a smoke bomb yeah
and people would freak out and he told
the story about lighting the smoke bomb
and running out of his head when they
threw him out and he had red eyes he's
got to call his mother because he was
14. that was us
concerts were the biggest release you
know they were man without him i'm dead
and now i don't know i feel [ __ ]
terrible
my wife had tickets to go for me to go
see
nine inch nails and and whatever i had
surgery the next day and i was like [ __ ]
and i wanted to go but i thought about
the hollywood bowl it's a [ __ ] hike
up hills and you've got a [ __ ] park
on the bottom and here i am with a
busted meniscus walking up a [ __ ]
hill and then if you gotta pee god
forbid you gotta walk down the hill and
pee and walk back up the [ __ ] hill i
want to see the stones that i left at
the threesome i was on that tour i was
smoking i was smoking cigarettes and i
had a i had a monkey in my pocket yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] about the stones i
watched three songs i love them to death
i had already seen them in 78 and 81 i
was like you know what yeah
some girls tattoos
some girls in philly yeah yeah they
recorded that with our foreigner yeah
with him foreign
i just said on my podcast last week
foreigner is underrated man one of the
best voices in music whatever that guy's
name is yeah bran one of the best voices
in music head games uh cold as ice dirty
whiteboard first album unbelievable the
first down my it was a monday a day like
any other day all that [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
tremendous tremendous this band is great
man they're an american treasure man or
where i don't even know where they're
from no they're from england yesterday
they're uh they're like
an american rock and roll band though
the sound is classic rock you know who i
love you know who still
i love zeppelin i love ac dc i love
sabbath with all my heart but one of the
best bands of all time to me and he is
the greatest voice in rock he's up there
with freddie mercury his back company
yeah i you know a lot of people know
that he was the only singer they
considered replacing jim morrison when
he died right i don't even think he had
free yet free is unbelievable but i just
watched i watched it a couple years ago
when
he sang for queen at the vh1 rock awards
and he did the the song must go on yeah
and you have he's got a wig now
weird yeah he does that he does have
that wig but he's built he's a karate
expert he's a black body and he always
wanted to that's why they broke up
because he kicked kirk in the [ __ ]
mountain
he broke his jaw with a kick
what's the guy's name the guitar player
from back up the good one oh
kirk
simon simon kirk simon kirk he broke one
of their [ __ ] jaws either him or the
other guy don't quote me i went to
desolation angels in 78 when i came back
from five star basketball camp since i
got my buddies like get in the car we'll
go to nassau coliseum and the [ __ ]
drummer did something then the lights
went out and the drumsticks glowed in
the dark and we had eaten like acid or
mescaline or something my head almost
[ __ ] blew up but i remember that he
was one of the one thing i didn't
understand about live music was
something you said
you said that you know when you see
somebody in the studio
they sing like that and then when you
see him live you're like
yeah he was to the t she still is right
now just like uh the guy from priest
that solar angel was that time
so hey and when he the victim of change
is live you'd be like
i'm good
yeah i'm good because towards the end
ozzy osbourne supposedly had like a back
singer in the back right that would sing
from i don't think he's doing on this
tour i heard this tour sabbath is just
[ __ ] tremendous
yeah i i i i don't know i heard jim
norton a couple days ago i listened to
jim norton a lot of love jim and i love
jim florentine the friends uh
florentine's a friend of mine and and
don jameson and um
and
you know sometimes i'll be like hey man
you're [ __ ] there i don't know the
singing's just not there anymore and
they just completely deaf ear me like no
man no they're great
i'm like oh come on man we saw him but
but norton said something funny a couple
days ago it was awesome he said yeah
they don't play uh
symptom of the universe anymore sabbath
and he goes i think cause ozzie can't
hit the notes and he goes i don't care
though sing it shitty if i want it
perfect i'll put on the record i just
want to hear the song and i was like
that's a [ __ ] pretty cool outlet
because i used to be kind of negative on
it you know like man the singing's
horrible
but now i'm just like well
they're there you know and they're
once these bands are gone
they're gone you know what i mean what
what are we gonna say there there's not
gonna be anybody we're gonna go see
so what do you guys think about
lip-synchers then
like when there's always like a
lip-syncing
uh catastrophe for something every every
six months like actually whatever and
is it do you like are you negative about
it or would you rather they just do that
i don't want to see somebody [ __ ] lip
sync i think it's the [ __ ] crime
of the business but then people would
pay 250 to see britney spears lip sync i
get it i get it when somebody jumps up
and down at the beginning of the tour
and they're out of shape
i get it when janet jackson starts her
tour in denver that when she first
starts to tour she's singing 15 of the
tour by the middle of the tour she's
handling it to 85 percent it's a little
music because she moves around
i get that
but i don't want to [ __ ] see
robert plant lipstick yeah you know led
zeppelin never did a tv performance
because they maintained a certain
patois what they were going to do and
what they weren't going to do i'm going
to give some sponsors a shout out so i'm
going to get back to you on something
real important first off as usual
[ __ ] on it especially now for
the holiday season tell that freaky date
and tell your mom your grandfather you
want to be a strong mental [ __ ]
savage go to honor.com it all starts off
with alpha brain money back guarantee we
don't even want the [ __ ] product back
that's how much we believe in the
[ __ ] product okay number two shroom
tech it's a winter season you're flying
you're on trains you're hanging out with
all these [ __ ] foreigners eating
hummus and [ __ ] you don't need that
aggravation take the [ __ ] shroom tech
so you're covered no ebola
what else does ahmed had how that has
beautiful kettlebells and it has battle
ropes and it has so many things going on
they have the mci juice with the coconut
so your flavor your smoothies and
whatnot go to honor.com right now see
what they got treat yourself for
christmas be a good friend to yourself
[ __ ] go to honor and press church
in the [ __ ] box and get ten
percent off that's how we run they could
stay on it for somebody for christmas
and you can stay on it they don't have
to leave the [ __ ] house the pills get
delivered right to their house okay
number two i want to give a tremendous
shout out to iron dragon tv i [ __ ]
opened it up with my wife the other day
i love what these guys are doing listen
you're going to get home some night
there's not going to be nothing on your
150 [ __ ] directv that you're paying
smoke a number do a few bonkers all the
chinese to go go on iron dragon tv watch
what they got you know what open up with
this get two free movies what do they
get they get two free rentals for and we
press joey and joey for two free ones
they got the hip man series they got the
cha young fat they got dennis chan they
got [ __ ] you don't even know [ __ ]
exist this is why if you're a martial
art enthusiast you like people flying
through the air japanese people stabbing
each other
irondragontv.com go there right now stop
[ __ ] around do a bonget go get your
two free movies two free [ __ ] movies
these guys got big things coming on the
4k comes out in september january you
ready for the [ __ ] 4k no iron dragon
tv is [ __ ] ready go to
irondragontv.com
now get your two free movies on the roku
why are you [ __ ] around looking at me
all right what are they gonna press in
the box like really joey j-o-e-y get
your two free [ __ ] movies today it's
the holidays you're gonna sit there
thanksgiving with your thumb up your ass
after the game your grandfather's gonna
tell you about world war two whatever
the [ __ ] you know what gramps it's time
for iron dragon tv [ __ ] [ __ ] bird sit
down watch a kung fu movie and let
yourself go hitting
listen it's the holiday season you're
sitting there smoking like a chimney you
sound like you got emphysema in your
[ __ ] stop [ __ ] around go to
hittiesticks.com get the [ __ ] get your
lungs back [ __ ] like i did right
here boom a cigar hit e6 1200 guaranteed
hitch you want to quit smoking
cigarettes they got a 24 milligram 16
and eight and a zero work yourself in
one month i'm gonna stop smoking
cigarettes i don't need to smell like a
[ __ ] dick breath no more i don't need
to smell like i ate somebody's [ __ ]
for 12 hours you're a [ __ ] savage you
want to pick up chicks you want to eat
[ __ ] and then they'll have an itchy
[ __ ] snatch for two weeks that's how
you do it you got nicotine in your mouth
you eat that little monkey they start
chiseling you don't need that [ __ ] go to
hideysigs.com right now take a look at
the flavors take a look at the selection
just this alone the cigars the holiday
season you want to tell people [ __ ]
stories and blow smoke in their face
this is the [ __ ] e-cigar for you go
to 86.com right now and press in joey's
church oh [ __ ] and what do they get lee
i get 20 off 20 off who's giving you
that you got to go stand online and
smell armpits and bump into fat people
getting blenders and [ __ ] to make
milkshake you don't have to leave the
[ __ ] house black friday could suck my
dick and it's sucking your dick too if i
find that you're out there [ __ ]
around with these people i'm disowning
you [ __ ] go to headeysigs.com
right now see a selection they got start
the new year off smokeless [ __ ]
blowing vapor in his eyeball what are
they pressing the box joey's church
there you go
now the life i don't know what to tell
you about these guys the best vapor [ __ ]
you want to smoke wax you want to do all
that crazy [ __ ] you want you're [ __ ]
you want to burn out and listen to black
sabbath symptom of the universe go to
nailed it life.com see what they got to
offer they got the best vapor pen in the
market they're gonna give you twenty
percent off so it's 50 they're gonna
give it to you for 40. that's number one
number two you got a problem with
something you call dave boom you got the
piece the next day that's not all what
they got they also the inventor of the
gummy bears you want to die and see
lucifer's dick take a gummy bear 250
milligrams of [ __ ] heavy duty
thc wax i don't even know what they put
in the peanut brittle and the peanut
butter ari said he ate and did something
the other day it's [ __ ] tremendous he
did it on his podcast there you go go to
nailed it live.com and press in joey
diaz oh [ __ ] and get 20 off your first
vapor pen
sent right to your house why are you
[ __ ] around staring at me do it now
[ __ ] again on it irondragontv.com
nailed it life no hit e6 dot com and
nail their life
yeah let's talk about something here
before we close this [ __ ]
i
uh
i think i was into the doors first
i know songs on the radio 10 cc i'm not
in love
and then one day i heard this explosion
and there was an album called led
zeppelin too i went to a party in
somebody's
basement and i'm listening to
heartbreaker and
i don't know
my heart just stopped
what is this
let's happen god damn it this is the
last band i wanted to [ __ ] like you
know
i went home and i put on led zeppelin 2
i bought it and
that's it
it changed my life i had stolen uh
a [ __ ] thing with the four speakers
two that came with it and then we wired
up puerto rican rigged two extra
speakers so you could hear a whole lot
of quadrophonic sound quadrophonic sound
and then i bought led zeppelin three and
then you buy
the [ __ ] zeppelin
one and then you buy four and then
you buy presents and
and then i buy uh
in through the outdoor i wait a whole
year and
you know when my mother died it was the
second hit because the first guy that
hit was bottom it hit me
i couldn't take that many knocks
i was at uh
this restaurant these guys are mobsters
now
moff and joe they had a [ __ ] uh egg
sandwich place and that's where i was
when
led zeppelin was about to go on sale
yeah and he died this guy had wplj in
new york was about to announce the
[ __ ] dates
and this guy dies and i buy the albums
and i smoke dope and i listen to led
zeppelin i work i don't like that but
everything i do is around led zeppelin
the style of my life is led zeppelin my
comedy is led zeppelin i want heavy yeah
i don't want no [ __ ] around i want to
kill his last name
we'll talk later let's blow up the room
now we'll talk later
and then i get older and i hear all this
[ __ ] that their thieves yeah
what am i supposed to do now now i know
in my heart i've seen the youtube videos
i've seen that they lifted some chords
whatever
now
40 years later
they the
lawsuit's going to move forward right
against led zeppelin with stairway to
heaven
they're your favorite band they're my
favorite band how am i supposed to feel
anybody how am i supposed to feel do i
stop listening to them
but then i put an hour mom that's called
the sauron maze the same which is a live
album
and unless you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
or you're a stupid [ __ ]
once you listen to that you know you
realize two things a that is probably
the greatest live performance that any
musical band has done i listened to
robert plan on the uh
uh power remember that old radio station
they had the the power flower howard oh
yeah sunday night king flower
and he said that you know the second
night in the garden jimmy page did
everything to that guitar that a human
could do except give it head yeah he
just destroyed him when he listened to
the album
and i know that you can't steal that
talent yeah and i know that uh you can't
steal achilles last stand and yeah i
know you can't when i listen to no
quarter when i listen to
dazed and confused and i listen to the
improvising i listen to it and then i
watch it on vh1 whenever it's on vh1
yeah it's on it's done whatever the [ __ ]
you told me shark tank whatever my wife
is watching i don't give a [ __ ] except
moby dick yeah yeah fast forward through
moby dick yeah if you go to my house
right now the storm is the same as on my
dvr
whenever i get down i just put a whole
lot of love
one night i believe i told you this
before all that [ __ ] to me you can't
steal yeah what do am i supposed to
think
well i
the way i look at it is
when they start out on zep one one and
two
they're like all those bands in england
man they're like a blues
acid rock band
you understand like
you're you're playing blues like you
know clapton all those guys cream and
stuff they're playing like white man's
blues you know
and
it it's i think it's more of like they
don't look at it as like they're
stealing they're playing
what they're they're influenced by you
know what i'm saying and then it's like
comics when you see them they first
start out you go oh this guy's doing
dice
you don't know absolutely absolutely
yeah until you find yourself and then
you find your voice
so
you're talking about jimmy page who
played on everyone's records as a
session guy
and he's been playing since he
was the stone all that [ __ ] he's on the
who he's on what stone helm is he on i
had it i got in the car
the sleepy city
yeah
it looks so pretty that one yeah my
buddy just bought it for me and gave it
because i said if it's there something
her majesty's secret service yeah that's
the one that that's the
everybody's on it yeah yeah plant is on
it uh a
couple people on it but the thing is so
he's playing blues his entire life
then they're going to do a record that
just i mean there's like you know like
acdc's like three chords that's blues
rock too if you slowed it down it's like
da da da da da da da
that's a [ __ ] blues progression
you know what i'm saying of course these
guys are like well they're doing howl
and wolf and he's doing this muddy
waters but the thing is everybody is
playing blues back then
and then you start to find your thing by
you know zeppelin three it's like holy
[ __ ] you know i mean going to california
that's zeppelin
you know now all that stuff is zeppelin
to me so i think it's like of course
it's gonna die make this clip yeah
uh just like two and that's one of my
favorite games of all time out and i
told somebody i wouldn't listen to no
quarter when i bought that arm i would
skip over with no quarters
that's how young i was mature yeah it
scared me it was too heavy when i first
got master reality
i didn't listen to it i bought it i put
it on one night the exorcist was on tv
i put earphones on i listened to master
reality and i was snorting t8 you're
going double satan which is [ __ ]
angel dust basically and i'm watching
all this going on i'm like i'll never
hear the sound again then it took me two
or three years to put into the void on
and go
wow yeah wow yeah you know now we're on
to something but no quarter at first
skip that [ __ ] go right to the
ocean [ __ ] but isn't it isn't it more
common with uh music than comedy like in
music people buy songs that other people
have written so it's not like
it's not like they're stealing but they
just didn't pay the royalties or is it
actually like they're stealing and poor
just something like later they later
they they gave him credit on on the
records i think it was early on i mean
early on they probably just thought they
of course we're playing blues uh but
everybody is you know what i'm saying
yeah music i have less of a problem with
than i would with comedy i think i don't
know why
listen when i heard that song by that
[ __ ] guy i knew he robbed [ __ ]
marvin gaye
which once i heard that song by robin
whip whatever robin thicke oh yeah yeah
in the night as soon as i heard that
song didn't take a genius to know they
had to pay somebody that was sampled or
clipped
okay did it but is that a [ __ ] mouse
over there
where what happened
did it bother me
no it didn't bother me i love uh
i love marvin gaye you know yeah
i don't know it's just a weird thing i
mean you know uh
what what are you gonna do
it's
to me i think that jimmy page was there
in the [ __ ] birth of that [ __ ] of
course he wasn't an old black blues
player you know but he played blues his
entire life
it wasn't like he just came in and
learned to style and then went okay
here's what we're gonna do we're going
to be blues rock
guy played blues all his life you know
played that skittle skibble or whatever
before that weird play you've ever seen
when he's like 13 on tv
playing something [ __ ]
did you know he's been playing guitar
always [ __ ] like that guy yeah you
know but as comics if somebody does if
somebody's stealing jokes we avoid them
oh yeah you don't call them i just avoid
them because i know i'm they're smacking
them so yeah they know so
why wouldn't we avoid zapping like guys
like you and me i can't i love it to me
if they stole something they made it
better they took it with confidence
this last uh lawsuit kind of threw me
off a little bit yeah uh to me it's
always been one of the greatest songs of
all time yep one of the greatest solos
of all time every time i hear it it
brings a tear to mine soul is insane
uh
you know hands down to me
again you know if you put on the soil
remains the same that's where i take my
that's a live performance at the hardest
venue
in the world
there's no harder venue and when you
watch it you see that the people are
hypnotized you know i got to see robert
playing jimmy page later on i saw that
too 96 yeah who gives a [ __ ] yeah it
wasn't let's have unto me i was happy
that's why i'm glad they never get back
together now it's never going to live up
to what you and i want it to be ever
we're good with the memories
i'm solid um
this morning i woke up and i wanted to
play this and this and this but i kept
hearing the opening quarter of achilles
look at my facebook and twitter that's
what i put on this morning
it's just a monday type of song it
wasn't early morning when they told us
we should know that song is a punch in
the face
it's one of the most
electric songs
that you hear you just go what the [ __ ]
man especially when they're playing it
at nebworth in 78
they play like a 79 or where they play
network they get they they're kind of
after 77 they lay dormant
then they're working on in through the
outdoor
and they haven't played in like three
years or whatever it is then they go do
two warm-up shows in nebworth and they
blue they also open up in the evening
yeah yeah and they're playing achilles
last night design the clothing on [ __ ]
and stop it
stop it yeah with those [ __ ] weird
suit pants and [ __ ] but jimmy page is
like weighs about 32 pounds in that and
he is murdering achilles last stand he
looks like he's possessed he's on heroin
full-blown addiction there and he's
killing it like beyond i love it man
it's [ __ ] insane
only some people know about that network
stuff that shit's fire
earth
network this fire
you know i heard the story of
i always talk about
what would have happened
is a great question
if uh here's what i gotta deal with
what would have happened
if leonard skinner gonna will lift ah
let's see if there's only two bands i
didn't see skinnard and zap one how
different would life had been what
direction all those bands molly hatchet
yeah all those bands would have carried
over because we couldn't i mean leonard
skinner was
way ahead of that time yeah but i heard
the story of them going to network and
just blowing out the stone yeah you seen
it you can watch it you're watching they
have like a little hat on and they're
doing saturday night special yeah and
you're sitting there going oh my [ __ ]
god they're in the spectrum of music and
they're just
killing it yeah i think that's ned worth
also yeah
yeah and they i mean they play
one of the most in spectacular i grew up
in the bay area and my whole music life
i owe to bill graham
everything my life i owe to that guy
because he had these visions of these
crazy shows where he'd put you know
[ __ ] all these different bands on and
that's how you got to learn about so
much different music
but the
skinner played dan the green and those
are my favorite shows ever dan degree
and i talk about it over and over and
over because it really [ __ ] me up but
if you punch in on youtube skinnered dan
the green free bird
you're not gonna see
anything more rocking than that
it's insane it's 60
it's 77.
it's 60 000 people
and they started up and he's like play a
pretty for oakland
that's what he says and and ronnie with
the no shoes on
burning up feet on the stage with that
[ __ ] hat on and the skin the neil
young shirt on because you know he had
that i hope neil young will remember
and there he is killing it you know and
you just go like that is [ __ ] rock
right there
you know and zeppelin played their last
two shows
in oakland coliseum 77 last two ever in
america
that's the ones where
peter grant and his uh his thug guy beat
up one of the uh guy's dads there
because the kid's pulling the led
zeppelin sign off the dressing room and
peter grant's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing get out of here and the dad comes
and they pull him in the dressing room
and just beat him almost to death
and then
i love this [ __ ] bill graham's like look
man
we can't cancel him because it's gonna
get [ __ ] crazy here uh so peter grant
knows that they beat that guy up so he
goes you got to come over here and sign
this paper saying you won't sue us
before we go back over there
they sign off on the paper they play the
next show and then the next day
plant's kid dies
like haunting in new orleans they're
supposed to play new orleans whatever he
goes home
and then the tour is cancelled
and then they don't play till 80 again
they do 13 shows in 80 and then bonzo
dies and that's it that's it
that's it a lot of people say that band
was haunted
you know 75 plant got in a bad car crash
canceled that tour his son died in 77
you know eric yeah just yeah just crazy
she always said the inside cover of
that's why i never understood because
house of the holy came out way before
the sun died yeah right but they said
the inside of the cover is him giving
his son up you know they had so many
[ __ ] yeah they're that's that's all
like twisted just right so many devil
[ __ ] that they had in references
now before we get the [ __ ] out of here
what day did you wake up and go you know
what
i'm gonna give this comedy a try
man it was
next it was a monday a day like any
other day it was a small town
i wanted to do comedy i'm 48 i wanted to
do comedy when i was uh
probably 12 years old i saw saturday
night live
first season
i wanted to be john belushi
i wanted to be that guy
i thought he was an absolute god he was
an outlaw he did drugs he [ __ ] drank
he rocked he really didn't give him
samurai [ __ ] don't remember
that case
i watch that [ __ ] saturday night stay up
barely awake oh [ __ ] falling asleep
watch it no we just watched the blues
brothers somewhere in a green room yeah
and if you're young and you watch the
blues brothers it's just a movie yeah
but if you know what he was going
through at the time and you're watching
belushi you're like
how the [ __ ] was he keeping it together
right this is oh my god animal house is
like
the [ __ ] epitome of face comedy
the way he could do a face
and you would just die you know
the eyebrow that [ __ ] thing where he
pops a boner and he falls backwards off
the ladder you know
all that stuff my brother and i would do
like the
the what is this the zit thing yeah oh
yeah all around the house yeah
but you know i got into that and then my
my uh buddy that turned me onto all the
rock had cheech and chong
and i was so into that that record i got
it now i got a mint version of it the
one with slide they're women in the car
whatever you know and the dog the
drive-in one where they sneak the guys
in
you know first gear they're like hey man
we got the people in the back you know
cheech and chong and then prior and the
prior and the carlin
and then later it was chris rock and
seinfeld
and uh in late 80s you know kennison and
dice my buddy dealt coke and he'd go to
the store and i'd stroll in and see dice
early on be like that guy never seen
anything like it just look at two
strangers and go is that your girl
what a [ __ ]
you'd be like whoa
man and then they would get up we're out
of here get out of here you crying
little hole
you know and that kind of [ __ ] and
you're like well this is gangster so i
always wanted to do comedy
but i was a kid kids didn't do comedy
there wasn't like you know you don't go
to a camp like my factory comedy camera
they didn't have that [ __ ] man so i
played rock in 25 years blue by boom
then
i got lucky i got that ice cube movie
this is about six
six years ago or so
and i'm two months in shreveport sitting
in bleachers with earthquake
and garrett morris
so not only am i meeting
[ __ ] ice cube who i worshipped nwa
i'm looking at the first season
garrett morris
that [ __ ] guy was on saturday night
live
when i was a kid ant-man
i can lift a thousand times my weight i
don't give a [ __ ] get out of here
john belushi is the hulk farting
you know
so i sit by earthquake
every couple days i go hey i want to do
comedy like what do i do
it's like ah man you gotta do open
mike's
not giving me much a couple more days
goodbye what else
you got it right man you got it right
right what what do i do where do i go
google it man get out of here you know
but after a month or so he realized i
was really interested in it
he goes all right i'll tell you what man
you do this you do that you do this
you get good come see me at the comedy
union i'll put you on and the year went
by i went on every day what was the
comedy yeah the comedy uh the movie no
no no the comedy union
oh the comedy unit yeah he was doing
wednesday night there
you know he goes you go and do open mics
and look me up when you think you're
ready
so i looked him up i went down i every
day 365
i did not miss a day
open mic every [ __ ] day never missed
a day
i looked him up i knocked on it i went
down to the union i go hey man it's me
dean he's a huh i go yeah maybe you told
me if i was ready so i didn't think you
were gonna do it man i mean i would have
told you some real [ __ ] i was just
telling you dumb [ __ ] out there bored
but i went on and had a good set you
know and um
and and
for you know i'm on my fifth year now
i've almost done 2500 spots
and i don't miss a day
maybe 10 days out of the five years
you know
but i every [ __ ] day
everywhere man i go to bakersfield for a
[ __ ] open mic eight minutes i heard they
give you eight minutes in bakersfield
i'm there
all on a motorcycle
you know what i mean oh i heard they'd
give you 12 minutes down in the ghetto
at this place called the family room
no whites in there i'm going you know i
mean they give you fried chicken you
ever doing that one they're in some
house
in south central man
in a house they cook chicken in and you
do comedy and if they like you they
throw dollars at you it's awesome i'm
gonna take leave down there you gotta go
there man no that sounds terrible but i
was going everywhere still right now i
just did eight days with russell peters
ten thousand people a night the day i
got home i went to westwood to the
irvine or to the improv space and did an
open mic
just to get back on the ground grounded
that audience isn't mine you know what i
mean i want to make that audience mind
so i gotta keep working you know just
grab five years
five years in god bless you next week
actually
on thursday thanksgiving day is two year
anniversary of my name painted on that
wall
at the store i got past november 27th
two years ago and that was out of my
life of doing everything i've done
was the proudest day of my life
when you drive down sunset strip you
look to the right my name's on that wall
[ __ ]
mind-boggling
i never thought i'd get my name on that
one right i was there in 88 snorting
coke drinking booze around those names i
didn't think i was ever even gonna do
comedy
there i am i didn't think any of this
[ __ ] was gonna happen i didn't think i'd
be going to philadelphia
selling on shows and people telling me
that the podcast has changed lee's life
i didn't think
half the [ __ ] that's going on right now
you know you can't imagine this you just
keep
there's one point you come to term with
being here and the things you have to do
and you just put your head down and
start doing them
and things pop up you know people always
say hey what do you want me to say about
you before i go on stage don't say
anything yeah say coming to the stage
joey d is i'm a can i'm a stand-up you
know yeah credits don't mean anything
they don't know they really don't you
know
it's been [ __ ] great man i'm happy i
finally uh and this is what really
happened guys
about a year ago jordan came up to me
maybe a year and a half ago jordan comes
up to me goes hey man you know a lot
about music why don't you talk to dean
delron and go i don't know [ __ ] dean
delray he goes he says he knows you i
don't listen what the [ __ ] y'all me i
don't know dean delray i knew you for
years yeah i just didn't know i thought
your name was marty
i didn't know why marty i was telling
you i'll tell you the idea i didn't know
why marty yeah you don't you don't you
haven't made it as a joey ds friend
unless you have a nickname like the
agostino and yeah i didn't know [ __ ]
it was right there marty marty dean
delray i got so many guys confused
there's three or four eric
yeah yeah something there's a guy that
does videos with people
he looks like him you remind me of him
so when i see finally i went to the
store and all you guys were together
like oh [ __ ]
i've been [ __ ] up for a long [ __ ]
time because i don't know names
especially now there's so many kids
coming up and guys you don't really know
and then they finally tell you their
name when they then you bump into them
and go oh it's you okay now i [ __ ]
get it brother thank you oh dude
comedies saved my life and and uh
you know between the death squad people
and marin and burr
you uh guys like russell ian edwards
i have i mean i was 44 years old in
hollywood
and played music
all my life and stepped off the train
you want to talk about
[ __ ] insanity and noises in your head
you're in the hollywood hills in a
[ __ ] guest house sitting there going
now what
now what man 25 [ __ ] years playing
music what am i gonna do
i don't have any friends here all my
people have married and moved on
and then you slowly start to get these
friends
and you go [ __ ] man like a guy like you
we're similar age we love music i could
talk to you for hours you could do this
till six nights that's what i'm saying
hours man marin i could talk to that guy
for
i mean he is like music comedy all you
know everything we can talk about and
i'm like [ __ ] this is saving me
so i thank you man for having me on
hundred percent i'll do it anytime and
come do mine okay yeah yeah i didn't
know what days you're doing i do it any
day you wanna do you come over and you
gotta come to my house because if you
like zeppelin you're gonna lose your
mind red band came over yesterday and
he's like i can't [ __ ] believe it's a
rock museum my house of my entire life
you're gonna see photos of me with slash
at [ __ ] like 21 years old that's
there you know axel me on a harley at 18
going on some biker run you know on
[ __ ] meth whatever it's just a
history in the myth
you ever do man yeah yeah i've done met
speed i don't [ __ ] know i've done it
all yeah just speed i did some good
speed in uh whistle west virginia went
into the mountains with some dudes to a
trailer i thought they were gonna give
me a blow
and i got some good coke in idaho those
[ __ ] black people haters they make
some good meth up there
yeah what the [ __ ] up with idaho they
got the best women it's like 1988
playboy just blondes with real boobs
[ __ ] women are getting beautiful and
beautiful everywhere last week in
portland there was some beautiful there
was a redhead who came down from canada
i love 26 that was beautiful she hasn't
hit me up on twitter or nothing oh oh my
god she was beautiful not that i want to
[ __ ] her and then i can't i got nothing
for her yeah i'm just saying she's gonna
say thank you wait are you married yeah
i'm married i got a two-year-old kid at
the house
i'm [ __ ] done i'm done uh
you know this week in philadelphia at
the airport i seen two black girls when
i got off the plane that were working
there ah that was beautiful sunday
morning i bought a breakfast burrito
from a chick from my bowlerville yeah
like she had the whole to get up on yeah
this chick was [ __ ] hot a hot
beautiful sister are you bowling
have you been to prague
no i don't have a passport the felonies
they took them away oh let me wait i got
a bowler there yeah no well they got
them probably let me tell you something
about probably about women
the most incredible women i think on the
planet come from the eastern bloc
and prague is the capital man so you got
russia budapest uh prague
prague everywhere you go you're at
mcdonald's and anna kournikova is making
your big mac
i'm telling you on the [ __ ] streets
on the hot dog stand it's anna
kournikova you got anna kournikova at
the [ __ ] taco bell you got to drive
in the bus wherever you go you what the
[ __ ] is this man any of them could move
to beverly hills and rock this
[ __ ] rocks meanwhile they're
making hot dogs for three dollars can
you believe it
they don't even know it's like when you
go to tennessee sometimes you go up to
the hills to some yeah and you see a
blonde and you're like that [ __ ] don't
know yeah but if she went to sunset and
just stood there that'd be 18 car
crashes yeah i gotta pull up and go
you're rich get in get in it's over for
you yeah this is the last time you're
gonna be able to walk down the [ __ ]
street
understand really saying what do you got
planned for tomorrow at least i had
we have something in the morning and
then uh
just the gym i think
i'm josh wolfe you're all [ __ ] up i
love it
yeah you're just like
i ate 10 milligrams don't don't [ __ ]
don't 10 minutes
how old are you i'm 26. did you ever do
any coke no no i never was i barely got
some lettuce in the house i'm a spike
i'm a [ __ ] brownie with mushrooms and
ecstasy he did that to me already he's
he gave me mushrooms and i thought they
were weak i'm gonna give him a half a
head of ecstasy and put in like a
mushroom brownie and send them home with
his little mexican girlfriend mushrooms
are the best she's gonna [ __ ] be on a
plane to mexico
and gave somebody a stabbing no that
little dick is going against that little
pink handle struggling
you go home and show that [ __ ] to your
girlfriend should go [ __ ] bananas
just tell open up wide say ah
it's over you understand me
i want to do some shows with you man
like one week and you and i hit san fran
or something something okay that'd be
dope right we just come in there and
invade it oh i was just there and i'm
gonna go back up there like in march oh
yeah podcast i was tweeting yours that's
right that's right you were somewhere
you know it's funny i got us
lee and i had to talk this morning we're
taking the podcast on the road in 2015.
it's great we're going to new york
philadelphia
new jersey
chicago
san francisco
sacramento modesto let me tell you [ __ ]
yeah san diego my favorite one in las
vegas my favorite women are jersey isn't
that weird jesus christ i love jersey
women and you hook up with them all the
time i try you know but i'm not too nice
you're too nice and you gotta have like
a missing [ __ ] eye
you have a union job a missing eye it's
that looks just easy woman look you know
what i mean beautiful i love that they
all look they all have the same look
like prague has the same look i can meet
a woman and go you from jersey oh how do
you know it's like i just like east
coast girls me too i'm an east coast
girl guy man well yeah i mean i like
classy women that dress nice they got
their own job
i don't need to see your titties and
everything hanging out i like like a
sophia coppola you want them to hide
those titties i like when they hide that
titties too yeah hidden treasures i love
when they hide that titties that's that
shows your [ __ ] confidence i love
that and they got their own kids yeah
that's a beautiful that turns me on more
than a chick that has a [ __ ] cleavage
up i don't need that i like women with
power yeah me i got my own company uh i
don't care what you got i don't need it
if we like each other it's on we're a
team we're a power couple i like that
too but i found in the east coast a lot
of girls get like i never i fought all
the time with all my ex-girlfriends from
boston i get out here i haven't fought
once with paula like i i don't know if
they're more high stronger or maybe i
was dating bad ones but the east coast
ones was vital because you're not eating
their [ __ ] yeah and now this one
don't let you eat her ass so she don't
like it so you got friends now yeah he's
close i gotta bend over and show you
that [ __ ] muffler
ready he already said okay you don't
need batman he goes i'd rather not
he'd rather not do anything i love you
brother thank you thank you man rock and
roll i want to thank annette i want to
thank uh
irondragontv.com hitysigs.com and nailed
the life where are you at next week
you're on the road anyway we want to
push it uh yeah what do we got here oh
i'm going to be in indianapolis with
russell peters at crackers december 4 5
and 6. that was my gig and russell
bumped me that [ __ ] now i'm going
in march oh really yeah yeah because
he's getting ready for the garden so
yeah um
crackers downtown not the uh not the
other one uh please come see me meet me
and uh hang out man uh saw some rock
stories [ __ ] and listen to my
podcast i let there be talk on all
things comedy and then uh this wednesday
we're doing a live podcast the guest is
joe rogan and thursday thanksgiving
we're doing a special [ __ ] thing here
at nine o'clock we're gonna bring some
turkey sandwiches no that's dope yeah
and just talk some [ __ ] on thanksgiving
night you know if you're around
i'll come down i feed the homeless every
year on thanksgiving at the last week
yeah
but i'll come yeah i can't take that
[ __ ] down that drives me crazy
i tell you what you get a sore arm yeah
i always get [ __ ] the mashed potatoes
i want to hit them in the [ __ ] head
they're too [ __ ] picky and they give
you the evil eye [ __ ] you you're getting
a free piece of turkey and you give me
[ __ ] attitude [ __ ] you i'm walking
out of the house to be nice to you the
one year i went down and they were like
[ __ ] you
come by the house i'll give you a turkey
sandwich i love you stay black again to
all my sponsors we love you one more
time to dean delray on it iron dragon tv
hit east.com and nail the life stay
black see you wednesday night at the
[ __ ] world famous ice house 8
30 p.m be there or be square lee is
going deeper than deep that night again
you just glazed over that's a fun guess
for wednesday i'm excited yeah [ __ ] it
we're doing it and then yeah joe rogan
yeah i'm gonna do the first set [ __ ] i
brought him on stage at the uh comedy
store last week tremendous
it was incredible to bring him up and
then the guy that stuff he was doing was
killing me he's got this new stuff about
just internet bloggers or or youtube
commenters and stuff and i was dying man
guys [ __ ] great
beautiful hit it [ __ ] all right uh
this show is brought to you by
sometime so it's brought to you by
honest.com use codeboard church to get
10 percent off
if you go to hit esigs.com that's hit
the letter e6.com you're going to get 20
off of the best e-cigs and e-cigars
uh better tasting longer-lasting the
proof is in the vape use codeword joey's
church to get twenty percent off
go to nailed it life.com that's nailed
it live.com and use uh cobra joeyds to
get 20 off of the premier vapor pen on
the market uh it's good for oil and for
wax
and go to irondragontv.com
and use codeword joey to get two free
rentals of any of their martial art
movies in the 8-man series uh it's joey
and you get two free rentals
awesome